so Christine Ford the accuser of Judge
Cavanaugh has has now presented a list
of demands conditions that must be met
if if she's going to testify and put her
allegations on the record here's the
Huffington Post with their report on
these conditions says attorneys for
Christine Ford port reportedly presented
the Senate Judiciary Committee with a
list of conditions on Thursday moving
forward negotiations for hearing before
the committee next week some of the
conditions included Kavanagh not being
present during blazes testimony and for
the committee to not turn the hearing
into a media circus oh yes
yeah the committee they're the ones
turning this into a media circus
attorneys Debra Katz and Lisa banks
offered these suggestions during a call
held with committee staff members on
Thursday night the negotiations for the
hearing mostly focused on logistics and
safety issues elastin about 30 minutes
during the call blasts ease legal team
asked that Cavanaugh speak first at the
hearing the attorneys also asked if the
Senators could preside over questioning
instead of bringing an outside counsel
with no female Republicans on the
committee the the Senators considered
using their female aides to question
Blasio at the hearing her attorneys also
asked if the committee could subpoena
mark judge who's the other guy that was
allegedly there they also discussed
having only one camera in the room
during the hearing and asked if the
hearing could take place on Thursday
instead of Monday okay so she wants to
delay the hearing until Thursday she
doesn't want any lawyers there she
doesn't want to be questioned by the
aides of the committee member she wants
to be questioned by the committee
members themselves
she doesn't want Cavanaugh there and she
wants Kavanagh to testify before her now
it's interesting that she doesn't want
the female aides to come in and question
her and she doesn't want any lawyers
there she doesn't wanna be questioned by
lawyer she wants to be questioned by by
by these Republican men right now I
wonder why that is could it be that Ford
wants the damaging and embarrassing
spectacle of a bunch of old white men
asking her about her alleged teenage
sexual assault it is that does she want
to embarrass Republicans and to and to
damage them well yeah that's exactly
what
she wants obviously but I asked you this
a traumatized woman who is just seeking
truth and justice does she act like this
is that is this how she goes about it
does she make these kinds of
calculations is she is she is
politically strategic as this if she
just wants to tell the truth and get the
truth out there is this what she's doing
does this make sense and then you have
worst of all you have the demand that
Cavanaugh testify first this is
unbelievably absurd and this is where we
have to kind of take the you know
there's no way to dance around it and
try to be nice to a Kristine Ford and
everything no this is just wrong
that she wants Cavanaugh to defend
himself against allegations on the
record before the allegations have been
made on the record she wants him to
defend himself against her charges
before she's made the charges so what is
he defending himself against rumors
media reports the stuff that he saw on
Twitter no this is crazy there's a
reason why in a court of law you get to
face your accuser number one and number
two your accuser makes the accusations
first and then you go they make the
accusations they present whatever
evidence they have and then you go you
know but what Ford wants and what the
Democrats have won they want innocent
they want guilty until proven innocent
they want they want to the presumption
of guilt and then for then a Kavanagh
has to prove his innocence prove a
negative proved that he didn't do
something at some point thirty five
years ago and they want they want him to
do that before the actual allegations
have been put on the record this is this
is inexcusable it's wrong and it it
makes Christine Ford look like a liar
that's what it makes her look like she
is presenting herself as a liar and a
manipulator now I don't know if she's
either of those things but that is how
she's presenting herself right now and
there seems to be this certain you know
attitude that well because Ford is a
victim
she should get to do what she wants and
she's above criticism but there's a
problem with that attitude first of all
I'm not at all convinced that she is a
victim you know that's the that that's
the the the we don't operate under the
assumption that she's a victim she has
to prove that and she hasn't proved it
so you know liberals are obviously gonna
operate under the assumption that she's
telling the truth but they're operating
under that assumption because it would
be politically convenient for them if
she if she were telling the truth
so that's why they decided that she is
but of course in reality we have been
given no reason to believe forward at
this point we've been given a lot of
reasons not to believe her you know the
lack of evidence the lack of detail the
way this stuff has been presented her
unwillingness to just come forward
straightforwardly and tell the story all
these things they they have they have
only enhanced the credibility of
Cavanaugh and they have detracted from
it from her credibility so we have been
given no reason whatsoever at this point
to believe anything she's saying she has
acted every step of the way like a
political agent she has acted like
somebody with an agenda okay and that is
an agenda beyond simply telling the
truth and here's the other thing even if
she is telling the truth even if she did
have this experience with Cavanaugh 35
years ago which again I'm not at all
convinced that she did but even if she
did that doesn't mean that she's beyond
reproach it doesn't mean she gets to
dictate terms it doesn't mean that that
we can't hold her to some kind of
standard it doesn't put her above
criticism this is one of the worst
things about about modern American
culture a modern American culture is
this idea this idea that victimhood puts
you above criticism above scrutiny and
we say well she's a victim so it's oh
it's okay no no that's wrong whether
she's telling the truth or not and I
don't think we are getting the truth
from her at least not the whole truth
but how she has handled this situation
has been in my view simply wrong
terribly wrong awfully wrong starting
with the decision to hold on to the
story for 35 years and then drop
like a bomb into the middle of a Supreme
Court confirmation hearing listen I you
know I know I know not everyone will
agree with this but I really think that
if you have a terrible experience if
something terrible happens to you like
the thing that Ford alleges and if
you're gonna come forward and tell that
story at all it's reasonable to expect
that you do that sometime before the
thirty-five year mark okay and if you
wait that long and you've told no one
and you have no evidence well then you
know what it's too late you waited too
long you waited until there's no chance
that you can prove your allegations and
now you're coming forward at the worst
possible time and you could say well she
just wants justice what she didn't want
justice after right after it happened
she didn't want justice five years after
it happened ten years after it happened
20 years after it happened 25 years
after that 30 years after it happened
she don't want justice any of those
times and now she suddenly wants justice
I don't know you know I'm sorry I just
don't and not only did she wait this
long but she's been playing these games
I will testify I won't testify okay I'll
come but here my conditions I don't want
one camera there I don't want him there
I want him to go first I want the
committee members I don't want the
female aids I don't want lawyers so on
and so forth and the whole country has
to wait with bated breath while
Christine Ford's decides what she wants
to do and this is okay because why
because because she says she was
assaulted 35 years ago no you know that
that's crazy it doesn't justify it it
doesn't victimhood does not give you
this kind of currency where you get to
do whatever you want without being
subject to any kind of scrutiny you know
Donald
Donald Trump sent out some tweets this
morning and he's getting a lot of
criticism because he said well you know
if this happened why did she call the
police and and and yeah I know there are
plenty of times when somebody is really
victimized raped you know etc and they
don't they don't go to the police for
any number of reasons you know they're
afraid they're confused they have guilt
today whatever so much so many different
things but but I think it's still
legitimate question is it's a totally
legitimate question because you never
went to the local police and now you
want the FBI to investigate 35 years so
yet all that time you never went to the
local law enforcement and then and then
35 years later you want the FBI to
investigate I think it's a perfectly
reasonable question to ask why didn't
you ever report this to anybody that is
a very reasonable question and it
deserves an answer and it's an answer
that should have already been given and
I think there's a there's a very real
question to be asked about like even if
something like this happened even if
something like this happened is it the
right thing to do to come out 35 years
later to try to use it against the
person while they're on the cusp of some
kind of you know promotion or something
like you hold on to it all this time and
now you want to use it to destroy them
35 years later is that really the right
thing to do does it automatically become
right because of your victim status I
don't think so
now let me stipulate one thing I I don't
think that Christine Ford is the villain
in this situation I think she's made
decisions and behaved in a way that is
pretty inexcusable but the villains are
the Democrats and they obviously are
using her they are happily eagerly
destroying Brett Kavanaugh and they're
pretending suddenly to care about women
even though they didn't care about women
when Bill Clinton was raping them
allegedly they didn't care about women
Kennedy drowned one in his car so now
they're pretending to SAR they're Liars
but what makes this even more disgusting
what makes this just so dark and evil is
the reason why they are doing this yeah
the reason is they want to prevent
obviously Cavanaugh for being confirmed
but why do they want to prevent why are
they so desperate to prevent it in fact
they're so desperate to get rid of
Cavanaugh with it now there's a few
Democrats have gone on the record now
and said that even if Cavanaugh is
confirmed when the Democrats are in
control of Congress they're gonna
investigate him anyway that's how
desperate they are to get rid of them
that they will investigate a sitting
Supreme Court justice for because of
allegations from 35 years ago so when
they get into power they want to impeach
impeach the president and they want to
get rid of a Supreme Court justice but
why why are they so desperate to stop
Cavanaugh from being a Supreme Court
justice well we all know the answer the
answer is abortion you know there's a
reason why Supreme Court hearings turn
into a circus
only after roe v wade Democrats are
desperate to hold on to their ability
and their power to kill babies they are
owned by the abortion industry they have
sold their soul to the abortion industry
and and liberals have this godlike power
to kill babies and they are desperate to
hold on to it and they will do anything
that's what this is about so remember
that remember what this is really about
it's about killing babies all right I'm
gonna cut it off early I'm going to
leave it there hope you guys have a
great weekend Godspeed